It’s now just four months until MainPower
Stadium opens its doors to the public.
The Mayor, councillors and staff recently visited
the site and were impressed with the progress.
The main court area has seen a dramatic
transformation over recent weeks,
following the installation
of acoustic panelling, hoops,
scoreboards and the wooden floor
for the four interior courts.
Plywood linings are a feature in many
of the stadium’s rooms and hallways.
Tiling, electrical and plumbing work is also
well underway throughout the various offices,
meeting rooms, bathrooms and gym areas.
Outside, the exterior cladding is complete
and beech timber soffits are being installed.
Construction of the eastern car
park is also progressing well,
which will provide parking both for
the Stadium and adjacent tennis courts.
Attention now turns to the painting,
interior fit-out and signage,
with contractor Leighs on track
to finish construction in July.